here in Nevada over 2 000 people are  veterans or know someone who served  today the Southern Nevada veterans  Chamber of Commerce held its first vet  Fest the festival happened earlier today  in downtown Summerlin it's meant to help  veterans and promote their growing  businesses right here in our community  Las Vegas is a veteran-friendly town  they're friendly for businesses they're  friendly for people to come into  leadership role that's why a lot of us  decided so when we took off our uniform  to make Las Vegas home  the sngcc hopes to make the festival an  annual event after this you can find  more information to help out here  locally on their website